and with that we'll turn it over to
Madison perfect thank you too hopefully
you can hear me okay thumbs up if you
can great thank you
um yeah so unfortunately I lied at the
time that I submitted this talk uh we
were managing over 600 million uh openly
licensed Media Records and that now that
number has now breached 700 million and
that has caused some problems for us
which I will talk about in the
presentation
um but like these two lovely MC said my
name is Madison Swain Bowden my pronouns
are she her and I am a data engineer at
automatic going to talk about the team
that manages openverse so that's the
project that I work on I'm a sponsored
maintainer of openvars it's what I'm
going to be talking about today these
are the other sponsored maintainers
there are
um eight of us across six countries who
speak over seven languages we are part
of a automatic effort uh an effort that
was pushed forward by automatic called
five for the future which urges tech
companies to put five percent of their
efforts profits Workforce towards open
source to to help empower the future
there's some alumni here from Creative
Commons if any of you are familiar with
Creative Commons they came forward to
continue working on this project which
I'll talk about the history of in a
little bit
um I'm listed as the only only data
Wrangler on this slide but that's just
an official title only all of us sort of
do all of the things we have one
designer and then the rest of us are
kind of everything we have front-end
Engineers we've back-end Engineers I do
infrastructure work I do API work on top
of all the data stuff eight people is
not a lot to be running a whole search
engine so we kind of have to do a little
bit of everything
a bit about myself I'm a data engineer
by trade and have been since 2018. I
live in Seattle here with my wife and
pets had to drive across the lake though
to get here today I live in North
Seattle
and previously I've worked at a date as
a data engineer at the Allen Institute
for cell science and ukla which runs
speedtest.net if any of you are familiar
so today I'm going to talk about what
openverse is what's this project
and in order to do that I'm going to
give some context behind licensing and
like what use cases for licensing are a
lot of us are familiar with software
licenses but Creative Commons which I'll
be describing provides licenses for all
sorts of things
so what is open verse
if you go to openverse.org the section
on the right is what you'll see our
tagline is openverse is a search engine
for openly licensed media now I say that
and people start processing that
sentence and they rarely get past search
engine so I'm going to go through each
of these bits just to describe them a
little bit more
it's a search engine many of us are
familiar with search engines right
they're used to find and locate things
say let's let's open verse it
openly license is a little bit more
tricky so
the
items that we index are licensed either
primarily as public domain works or with
Creative Commons licenses and for per
Creative Commons their licenses are
tools that they provide everyone from
Individual creators to large companies
as well as institutions with a simple
and standardized way to Grant legal
permission to their creative Works which
can then be copied distributed edited
remixed and developed all within the
limits of copyright law
so that's a lot of legal terminology
here the purpose of these licenses
which I'll get into more in a little bit
is just to empower creators to have
rights over the work that they create
lastly media right now we have images
and audio images comprising the the vast
book of the the items that we index but
we also have uh goals to add different
media types like 3D models video and
text
so the point being if you were to search
bird
you're going to get pictures of birds
you're going to get
albums that have you know the title bird
in it that sort of thing
later down the line it will be textbooks
that have bird in them
Etc
so openverse started off out of Creative
Commons as a project called CC search in
2016.
and this was an effort to this was an
effort by Creative Commons who developed
these licenses as a way to Showcase here
are you know all of the different kinds
of media that people have licensed with
Creative Commons licenses
in
2021 they announced that they could no
longer maintain it was more expensive
than they could handle as a non-profit
organization and so at that point
automatic offered to take it over and
since then we have rebranded and turned
it into openvars and so this is like I
said this is what you'll see if you go
to openverse.org
and I had mentioned earlier
if you make a simple search
like water falling for instance the
results that come up are openly licensed
pictures of waterfalls of the the house
the architecture design water falling
right you have audio clips of
waterfalling songs that people have
called waterfalling
and in this aggregated View
on the right hand side there are a
number of filters and those filters will
let you select specific licenses so I'll
talk about those licenses in a bit but
that's sort of the power Google has
recently added in their image search a
uh like Creative Commons license images
filter on their search but they have no
distinction on which kind of license is
served by or which kind of license
you're filtering down into and these
licenses can have implications on their
use which are important to know about
so if you filter down to images too on
open verse then you have a bunch of
other additional selectors for things
like what kind of image it is what the
extension of the image is aspect ratio
and similarly for audio we have other
filters for that as well including the
category of the audio
the extension the duration of the audio
so that if you're you know looking for a
smaller clip you can filter by that as
well
so open verse is an aggregator right we
don't host any of this media we just
provide a means of searching against all
of the openly licensed media not all of
the the goal is all of the right but
many different pieces of openly licensed
media across the internet and so right
now I had mentioned we're primarily
image and audio we have some providers
like Flickr and NASA flickers by and
large our biggest provider they have the
most images in our data set but we also
aggregate images and audio from
things like museums libraries other
openly licensed stock photo websites
and then we have some providers like
Wikimedia Commons where we get both
images and audio as well
so
I'm going to talk about licensing next
again if there are any questions about
any of this as I'm going through please
feel free to ask I'm happy to to answer
that as we're going through
in order to talk about licensing I want
to take one step back and talk about the
commons this is the commons
that creative commons refers to when
they in as part of their name right and
the commons is this notion of the
cultural and natural resources that are
accessible to all members of societies
of a society
and described a different way
the the digital library of the commons
talks about the commons as a general
term for the shared resources in which
each stakeholder has an equal interest
and so this sort of perspective about
the commons as an entity or as something
that folks can contribute to is what has
driven Creative Commons to develop these
licenses that enable their creators to
yeah have licenses that are part of the
commons that folks can contribute to the
commons but they can still retain some
rights to as creators
yeah intention is to power them by
allowing them to share allowing creators
to share their work on the conditions of
their choice while still retaining
rights and this all is done through the
framework framework of copyright law
there's eight different license types
I'm not going to go through them all but
the important thing to note is that
there's just a variety of different
license types depending on your use case
so if you're a Creator and you want to
license something a particular way
similar to how one might license
software right with MIT or BSD or
whatever license type might be necessary
for or desired for your use case you can
also license creative works so if you
take a photo if you record some audio
right if you write a textbook those can
all be licensed with Creative Commons
licenses that have certain attachments
to them
so for instance some like licenses might
dictate that you can share uh
the adaptations but they have to be
shared under the same license type and
so I think that this has an allegory to
some similar licenses in the software
world or other licenses that say you
can't use whatever is derived from this
with commercial purposes
almost all of the licenses except for
the bottom two require you to attribute
the Creator if you if you end up using
this right but then the last two are
either public domain or rather yeah
public domain Mark or cc0 which is just
a a way to get as close to public domain
legally as possible
and those say I'm the Creator I'm
ensuring that this work in perpetuity
does not have any conditions to its use
but I'm acknowledging that as the
Creator and assigning this license to it
so the power I mentioned this a little
bit with Google right you can filter by
these licenses but again
if you're trying to find something for a
commercial purpose you might not be able
to know from Google image search which
license is going to actually allow or
what what image is going to allow you to
use that for a commercial purpose so
that's the power of open versus being
able to filter by these license types
depending on your use case
and additionally openfirst provides the
attribution text necessary for an image
or an audio record just as part of the
image page so if you find an image like
this is perfect this is great for my use
case you have the attribution text right
there in three different forms the rich
text HTML and plain text as well
so we'll talk about some use cases here
why might one want to use openly
licensed media
say you're writing a blog post and you
want to add content to a blog post this
incidentally is a blog post about
openverse that somebody wrote and they
used a image that they also Source from
open verse or found on openverse rather
and we're giving attribution to the
Creator for that post
um if any of you are familiar with
WordPress
automatic is does a lot of work in the
WordPress space and recently openverse
was integrated into the most recent
version of Wordpress so if you have a
site that's running WordPress and you
want to add media to that site the add
media screen also has an open verse
option and so you can search for media
in openverse on your WordPress site just
as you're writing a post or you know
what have you and then when you click to
insert that media
the attribution will come along with it
so you don't have to necessarily take
any extra time to add that attribution
you can acknowledge the creator of the
content without any extra work on your
behalf
oh and here's an example of that right
we have the attribution text that's at
the bottom
another use case
you're starting a podcast right and you
want some intro music for your podcast
you're not planning on making any money
on this podcast it's just something you
want to do for fun so you can use uh any
sort of uh any one of these licenses to
find music that can start at the
beginning of your podcast
in another example here perhaps we're um
we want to find a sound sample for a
mixed song So in that case there we
might be restricted on what licenses we
can use because some some media is
tagged with a license that does not
allow you to remix it or adapt it or
transform it and so those are licenses
we have to avoid
so that's all the introduction now I'm
going to get very briefly into the tech
stack
and then I'll get into the data stack
after this
so open versus powered by an xjs front
end which is running in ECS so if you go
and hit the web browser openverse.org
that's what you're going to see we also
have a Django rest API that's also
running on ECS and so you can use the
API directly if that's you know
preferred for your use case
and that interacts with an elasticsearch
cluster and a postgres database that
backs it
now the more interesting piece so as I'm
walking through this
this all comes with a bit of a caveat We
inherited most of the stack as the open
verse project from Creative Commons
um
and so there might be some things here
that are kind of interesting or unique
and those are those are the result of
just inheriting an open source project
and then continuing to Shepherd it into
the future
so on the right here we have the
postgres database in the elasticsearch
cluster that I mentioned before those
service are API but in addition to that
we have what we call our catalog
database which is also postgres and then
a bespoke data refresh server that's
running in Falcon both the catalog and
the data refresh server are managed by
airflow
meaning that any interactions that are
happening with them airflow is the one
that's orchestrating them
so here are some differences between you
might be wondering why do we have two
postgres databases I certainly was when
I first started on the project
on the left side we have the catalog
postgres database and then the right
side is the API database
and the one on the left has far fewer
indices than the one on the right and
the intention behind that is we are
um writing more heavily to the catalog
directly and we're writing to the API
very infrequently but we're reading from
the API quite frequently and in service
of requests right and so the API
database is heavily right optimized or
the the catalog database is more
um or excuse me the API is more read
optimized while the catalog is more
right optimized
so in the grand scheme of things right
if we put all of openverse in a box
data goes in by a way of from the left
hand side of this diagram by way of
ingestion from provider apis which I'll
talk about in a sec and then it comes
out of the openverse ecosystem by way of
API requests that are served to either
some client that's interacting directly
with our API or the front end
and if we zoom in on the left side
this is primarily how our data gets into
the catalog so we have these different
providers I had I had shown them um at
the very beginning those image and audio
providers those providers have apis that
we're able to interact with so Flickr
has an API another one is the WordPress
photo directory
um stocksmap is another provider they
have an API different
um like libraries and museums and other
institutions have their own apis
and so all of these have unique ways of
serving different kinds of data and so
we have a series of Provider API scripts
that interact with the rest apis
transform the data into something that's
more uniform and then inserts it into
the catalog by way of writing to your
tsv and then having that be pulled into
the catalog database
some of these happen so like flickr's
API will let us query across a day and
it even has resolution down to like a
couple of minutes so we can query what
were all the records that were updated
you know in this five minute time span
whereas there are other apis like stock
snap stock snap and the WordPress photo
directory as well
just provide their entire data set as a
iterative like a series of pages that
you have to iterate through so on some
we are reprocessing the entire data set
on a weekly or monthly basis and then on
others we're just Gathering the most
recent days worth of data and adding
that into our catalog database
we're also exploring some ways to do
bull congestion I'll talk about that
towards the end
but those are for providers that don't
necessarily have an API but still have
their data available
and so here are some examples of like
that what that process looks like so we
have airflow that manages this on a
schedule
and you can see we have a varying number
of records that come out of different
different providers some providers are
producing you know hundreds of thousands
of Records by the time that we we get
back to them or others you know we're
loading we'll say day by day and like
for instance Wikimedia Commons this was
a run from July of last year that took
25 minutes and had you know some varying
number of
but the difference with the bottom right
is here we have a single run from a data
source called inaturalist that ingested
15 million records
and so that was a uh our our first
attempt at adding that provider and the
time that that took was you could see it
said No data but that's not because it
didn't take any time at all that's
because it took too long
um
and so we ended up taking a different
approach with that particular provider
so that great we have data in the
catalog right but nothing is nothing new
is being served by our API
and so here's where that bespoke data
refresh server comes in and so this
happens with a a two broadly two-step
process of getting new data from the
catalog into the API the first step is
copying all of that data so as it stands
right now that's exactly what happens we
create a new table with the same
definition as one in the catalog we copy
all of the records from the catalog and
then we swap the tables in production
and then step two is updating the
indices in elasticsearch similarly we
just create a new index
insert all of the records from the API
into that index and then swap those
those indices in production
with a little bit more granularity and I
have the image sort of as reference in
the bottom right
we also get popularity information from
different providers and that popularity
information takes different forms so
Flickr might have like download count
whereas there are other providers that
might have like number of comments right
is the metric that we have available to
use as popularity and so as you might
imagine one of the greatest challenges
that that openverse has in terms of
ingesting this data is like the
heterogeneous nature of all of these
providers and so we have a step at the
very beginning which normalizes that
popularity information across providers
so that we can use a like the normalized
form when we're running queries against
elasticsearch
so that's the first step and that
happens on the catalog second step is
copy the table definition I mentioned
that and then the third step is we copy
all of the data from database to
database
and then step four and I noted this in
step two
um
inserting records with indices in
postgres
particularly at scale is not efficient
because every time a record is inserted
it has to update all the indices so it's
much more efficient efficient to copy
the the table with no indices move all
of the data over and then apply the
indices after the fact
so that's step four
and then once the indices are applied we
index all the data into elasticsearch
and then swap the tables into production
and so
um
we also have slack updates for when this
process is occurring ideally we run this
at the time like currently at a weekly
basis and so we have data that's coming
into the catalog constantly and then
once a week we do this data refresh
process to get new data into the API so
here's what it looks like for audio this
was a particularly red letter day for us
because the um
change that we got to audio was six
hundred thousand new records up from 170
000 so it was like a 350 increase in the
available production data which was
really stellar
so there are some advantages and
disadvantages to this the advantages in
One sensor that we have clear separation
of like what's production data and
what's data that we can sort of mess
around with right
there's also a time delay between when
we ingest records from a provider and
when we actually serve them on the API
and this delay can be used and has been
used by US to correct issues with the
source Data before they actually make it
to production
and additionally because the
um the Step At the very very end is just
swapping tables and postgres and then
swapping index aliases for which index
to use inelastic search and for those
unfamiliar with Alaska expression index
is very similar to like a table right
one might think of so we're just
swapping tables to use and swapping
indices to use there's very little
impact on production and so the rights
that are current occurring constantly to
the catalog database don't impact
production whatsoever
now there's obviously also drawbacks to
this approach right I said that we're
running this on a weekly basis which
means that if we get data in right after
a data refresh is run then that data
won't make it to production until a week
later and that's if the data refresh is
a media right for audio it's quite quick
but for our image data refresh it's
quite a slow process at this point
we also this approach also requires
maintenance of two distinct databases
and then lastly we have this data this
bespoke data refresh server which is
performing some actions but those
actions are being dictated primarily by
airflow and so we have a desire to
extract those pieces into airflow
entirely so that we can move away from
having to also maintain this this
bespoke data refresh server
so next I'm going to get into
reimagining what this setup might look
like right a lot of our time has been
spent spinning back up these providers
getting in touch with the institutions
to get like API keys and um generally
getting things back up and running from
the Handover from Creative Commons but
now that we have that we're in a space
where we can start to rethink what this
data story looks like
especially as we continue to increase
the number of like there's there's no
shortage of new Creative Commons works
that are being added to the internet at
any given time and so we definitely have
to be thinking of okay now we've reached
this point where we have 700 million
records how do we continue to support
this going forward
so one thing I mentioned with
inaturalists specifically is inaturalist
has an API and we use that API to sort
of crawl over their records but that
process was quite slow
they also provide bulk information about
their data so they have like the schema
that's listed on GitHub and then they
have tarballs that can be downloaded
with the actual contents of these
various tables from S3
and so one thing we worked on was moving
from this rest API interactive model to
inserting the data that they have
directly into the database and then
performing whatever Transformations we
need to do to get from their data to the
normalized form that we have on the
database itself
and so you had seen from the previous
screen that like the the different
providers that we have total range of
accounts that we get some are like 100
per iteration other providers like
around on the order of a million per
iteration whereas with this this
different approach where we're just
doing the ETL within the database and
not like trying to interact with a rest
API we were able to get 150 million new
records on a single iteration
additionally in terms of thinking about
you know how we might rework this stuff
this standardized popularity step is
currently a bottleneck for for moving
data from the catalog to the API so
that's a step that no data can be
accessed until all of the standardized
popularity for all of the data has been
recalculated for the entire data set
and right now that's uh that's that's
causing us some some difficulties
because of how much of a bottleneck that
is
for instance
this is a graph of like the final row
count in our API database versus the
time it took to run that standardized
popularity calculation
and so as we started off I don't have
like time here but you can imagine that
we're just generally increasing the
number of records that we have in the
API overtime
and so we were doing like pretty
consistently 12 or excuse me 15 16 hours
um and then we ingested a bunch of new
records for my naturalist and all of a
sudden that process time shot up to 60
62 hours
and this is this is live data as of
yesterday we have now reached I think
700 so that's at
726-ish million records we're now at 750
million records and the current process
time died after 21 days of running this
calculation at um sorry that should say
750 million records
um so obviously this is untenable right
because it now means that we're we're in
a position where we can't update our API
database without running this and so
um in terms of plan going plans for the
future one of the first plans that we
have one of the things that we're
working on right now is decoupling that
popularity calculation because we
shouldn't need to have like super
accurate popularity data in order to get
new data into the API right that's a
that's a benefit for search relevancy
but it doesn't necessarily it shouldn't
necessarily inhibit us surfacing that
data in searches
additionally we want to add things add
mechanisms to propagate information from
the API back to the catalog so the
catalog is just constantly consuming
information from the API or from the
various provider apis but there are
cases where a you know an image is
deleted from those providers or some
link no longer works right and that we
don't crawl over all of the data that we
have yet but that information might be
surfaced as someone is using the API and
they make a search and we have a sort of
precursor to the search that checks to
make sure that all of those links are
still live before we serve them
and so that information currently only
exists in the API and that sort of
information that we'd like to bring back
to the catalog to know which records are
still exist right
duplicate image detection right somebody
might have a creative work that they've
uploaded to several different
institutions or several different social
media sites for instance and so only
retaining one record of that is
something we'd like to achieve
and then further data normalization
across providers things have changed
since the project had started in 2016
and the the data that that we found has
been important or like different pieces
of the data that we found have been
useful has changed and so one of our
recent projects was to build out
consistency across those providers in
the way that we ingest the the providers
because previously it was like all of
the business Logic for each provider was
repeated in each provider script and so
now we have like a unified interface for
okay so you want to add a new provider
you only have to fill out these
functions that are specific for the
provider all of the mechanisms around
interacting with a rest API are
abstracted
and then just like these are these are
project ideas that we have up on GitHub
but more broadly like our thoughts going
forward are removed as I had mentioned
remove the bespoke data refresh server
and move more of those operations into
airflow
um I had described how we copy all of
the records from the API or excuse me
from the catalog to the API database
probably don't need to be doing that uh
we can probably switch from a copy all
into like an update right where we're
only copying the records that have been
updated since the most recent run
and then lastly switching from
ETL to elt meaning we currently interact
with these providers we pull data we
transform it into uh the form that our
database is familiar with and then we
insert it right and that initial form is
not something that we retain from the
various providers but what we have found
is you know frequently we or
occasionally rather we want to add a new
field or add some new piece of metadata
about these properties like image
Dimensions was one right where that
might be useful for folks on the front
end as they're trying to search for
images
if we wanted to reprocess or if we
wanted to gather that data we would have
to reprocess reprocess all the data from
the Upstream API
whereas if we were retaining the results
that we got from the Upstream as we were
interacting with the Upstream API then
even if we did transform it into the
step that we needed or the form that we
needed for the catalog database we could
still have that data to go back to
so all I have to say
my question to you all
has something to think about is knowing
the at that if we're thinking about the
black box of data comes in and data goes
out right
knowing the inputs being ingestion and
outputs being search and API
capabilities if you were to start the
open verse project from scratch how
would you design the bits in the middle
and note that there are constraints to
that question right we have massive
amounts of metadata that we're working
with that's very heterogeneous
we have Media Records that are going to
be updated so there's not just one
insert that's happening those records
might be updated over time
and then lastly Media Records might be
removed or they could be also reported
for any number of potential reasons on
our front end
so the good news here is that we're an
open source project and so we have a
strong community and there are numerous
ways to get involved into this project
we have a Blog up on
wordpress.org it's make.wordpress.org
openverse and then we also have like a
slack Channel within the make WordPress
space
and we hold weekly Community meetings
every Tuesday at 1500 UTC and that's in
slack not like on Zoom or whatnot and
it's all asynchronous over text and so
um if you're interested it's it's very
easy to stop by uh to one of those chats
because it's just in slack and that time
1500 UTC depending on daylight savings
time is 7 AM for me and so I take that
in my PJs a lot
as I mentioned all of our code is open
source we recently moved to from several
different repos into a model repo so
almost our entire stack here is in this
repository which is really cool
the only thing that's missing I have an
asterisk here the only thing that's
missing is our infrastructure definition
which is in a separate Repository
we have a really uh long contributing
guide that details all the various ways
to contribute both code and non-code
ways to contribute to this project we
have a lot of people who have
contributed just to the like DX
experience to the um
the design work of the project
translations are also a big piece we're
part of the WordPress ecosystem in that
sense and so there's a lot of ways to
contribute easily contribute
translations
based on your your language you're
comfortable with
and then I had talked a lot about
providers some of you might be thinking
like okay well I have
um you know I know a provider that uh
that has I know some
will say some Museum that has an API
that serves Creative Commons or public
domain images
um or if you want to help open first by
adding a provider we also have a number
of existing providers that we as
maintainers don't have the capacity to
write ingestion scripts for
and so there's quite a few of those and
I had mentioned this a bit earlier
but we have I would like to thank pretty
thorough documentation on what it takes
to add a new provider and we have
scripts that will set everything up for
you and all you have to do if you're
adding a provider is fill in the bits
that are specific to the transformation
from that provider's rest
excuse me rest results into like the
form that that is needed for open verse
and in fact that's exactly what happened
with our naturalist so the inaturalist
and jester
which was um one of the the bulk data
ingesters too that was all
um drafted and uh primarily developed by
someone from the community who was not a
sponsored maintainer
um and this was this was someone who was
um using open source to like learn how
to do Python and so it was really
encouraging to see like what they had
created and have that be a you know such
a significant contribution to open verse
another benefit about being open source
and something that we're putting more
emphasis on as a project is like doing
our project planning out in the open
and so we've we've recently started
doing this as of 2013 and on our
documentation site which is
docs.openverse.org we have all of the
different projects that we that have
been proposed and that are being worked
on here
and so this was an example
that was that's a project that I'm
leading that has has recently started
but then also again hot off the presses
one of my uh fellow collaborators has
been putting out plans for doing that
decoupling of the popularity calculation
and so if you have thoughts the reason I
bring this up is you can participate
like we we would love to hear your
thoughts and your contributions on
GitHub where all of this this work is
happening publicly
okay that's all I have thank you for
attending and I'm I'm open for questions
if you have any
are there any questions
[Applause]
all right I've got a question over here
and then I'll just be mindful of the
time because they're back-to-back
sessions but
as part of the reimagining exercise have
you considered either using like PG the
postgres vector search Plugin or even
using like an open source Vector
database rather than elasticsearch
So when you say oh like
you're saying is a replacement for open
or elasticsearch yeah
we have not I have not personally so can
you elaborate on what what these these
alternates are
oh I I'm not a data engineer I'm a data
scientist by training but I've recently
just read a lot a little bit more about
how postgres has a new search plugin
that works pretty well and you get rid
of that additional layer of using
elasticsearch
um and of course then if you use search
plugins then another sort of counterpart
that we can consider is using Vector
databases but this all of this is rest
upon assumption that maybe we are doing
similar research based on the vector
embeddings but that may not be the case
for you yeah so so open verse right now
like our our search is
um like I have to be honest like this
conference has been super helpful for me
because I've had opportunities to
interact with
um people who are much better at search
relevancy than I am and so it's
definitely like openverse does some
pretty naive things with regards to
search but the the vectorized embeddings
are something that like I'm part
regularly intrigued by and I think are
something that could significantly help
our our result relevancy and so I know
that elasticsearch has recently added
support for that a lot of the folks that
I've talked about have said that
um
it was recently added and so it's still
um you know kind of a new space
um but I'll take that into account as we
as we start thinking about like how do
we vectorize these results to give or
vectorize these records to give better
results yeah result relevancy I had
versus fact
um
yeah search search relevancy is like a
big question for us
um in terms of like how how do we as a
team of maintainers who don't have any
search experts Among Us how do we take
steps towards building more relevant
results yeah
thank you
thank you a really great talk uh my
question is related to the data sources
so right now as I'm seeing the data
integration is heavily Reliant like on a
manual API script ingestion with certain
providers is it at all feasible or do
you think it's possible somewhere in the
future to integrate it with like sources
without uh in a more generalized fashion
without having to work with certain
providers by like the way we scrape like
web data just to take in some website
and looking for the data with
in public domains or totally online
totally yeah that's a really good
question and it it that was actually
part of the history of openvoice
actually when it was creative search so
they um there was a process that existed
for ingesting common crawl data and
using that to determine or Define images
um in a way that didn't involve rest API
that infrastructure was expensive
um and uh was not something that we had
the capacity at the time to set up and
and restart essentially so
um that idea is out there and it's
actually baked into some of the history
of the project but it's not something
that we're doing right now
got another question
speaking of expenses how do you get
funding for the computation and the
storage and the serving and how does
price factor into the decisions that you
make
for a company it's kind of clear you get
revenue for building something and
deploying it but in a project like this
you need to make trade-offs for cost and
computation yeah yeah that's
we are pretty much entirely sponsored
and supported by automatic as part of
that fight for the future effort that
effort also includes lots of sponsorship
towards wordpress.org and a lot of the
the work the dev work the hosting that
goes into wordpress.org like as a as a
project and so costs are are definitely
on our mind right like if I
um
if I could you know wave a wand we would
have a much larger team with a much
varied expertise for for different
aspects
there was a lot of learning that we had
to do as a team on the infrastructure
side there's more learning that we're
doing right now on the search relevancy
side right and so I I yeah that that
factors in a lot to our constraints it's
just like who who do we have access to
what Brain Trust right do we can we can
we tap into be it like the community or
other folks that we know for for sort of
accomplishing this
um and certainly
the cost is cost is definitely a big
factor on the infrastructure side right
you'll you'll notice that um
were
using a lot of Open Source tools as part
of the part of the the back end for this
and that's intentional because we're
yeah just constrained in that way and so
we're fortunate that the open source
space which we're also a part of is like
really rich and we can build tooling off
of that
um
but that to say yeah it's very hard for
us to like
um
we haven't gotten to the point where
we've need to like make a big purchase
or anything and I I it will be a
um a long process to do that I imagine
yeah yeah does that answer your question
okay
in in this case
um
probably both uh but but certainly like
one of our biggest constraints right now
is labor
um like there's so much that we want to
do uh on the project and there's only
eight of us who are running the search
engine right and so um
yeah certainly like like labor itself is
is probably one of the bigger
constraints that we have yeah
how many and expertise right by by way
of Labor right
um particularly with like the common
crawl there was like
um
much of that's done or is or was done
with spark right and like none of our
team has expertise with spark as well so
that has effects too
how frequent are people searching open
verse
how many users a day is it oh
um
it's a great question how many users a
day does your small understaffed team
support is probably a better question
I uh I'm I'm I don't have metrics off
the top of my head but I I think it's uh
like hundreds of thousands of requests
per day
on the order of
awesome
yeah we don't we don't do a whole lot of
like user tracking um
yeah and so well
um yeah we're trying to in fact like
we've started doing user tracking or
we've started doing user analytics right
um but that has been a long process
because we wanted to be particularly
intentional about caring for user data
because this is like a free open source
tool and so that that has been a longer
project and a broader conversation that
has also occurred in the context of
Wordpress because the WordPress
community wordpress.org community is
also similarly wants to be cognizant of
like what data people are collecting so
all right we are at time so let's give
Madison a big round of applause this was
wonderful
[Applause]